and my party understands better than
others the importance of low taxes in
creating incentives and fostering the
animal spirits that spur economic growth
but another conservative Insight is that
risk taking by individuals and
businesses
can only happen when governments provide
economic and financial stability
so the best tax cut right now is a cut
in inflation
and a plan I set out in the Autumn
statement tackles that root cause of
instability in the British economy
the Prime Minister talked about halving
inflation as one of his five key
priorities
and doing so is the only sustainable way
to restore industrial Harmony